On his first full day in Canada,...
...Pope Francis delivered a historic apology for the quote,...
"...Evil committed by so many Christians against indigenous people."
His week-long trip centers around his response to the treatment of indigenous children...
...at government-funded schools,...
...the majority ran by Catholics from the 1800s to the 1900s.
Chris Livesay is travelling with the Pope.
At the site of a former residential school in the Canadian city of Masquatchies,...
...Pope Francis was greeted with sacred drumming and dance,...
...rituals the Church once sought to erase.
It was here the Pope issued a historic apology to a crowd of thousands,...
...most of them indigenous people.
I am here because the first step of my penitential pilgrimage among you...
...is that of again asking forgiveness.
That apology was met with applause from the crowd as was this request,...
"...I ask forgiveness."
People were visibly emotional, wiping their tears.
The Pope was given a traditional headdress to wear after his remarks.
The Pope began the day visiting what is believed to be a graveyard...
...for some of the children who never made it home.
For around a century, more than one hundred fifty thousand native children...
...were taken from their families to attend government-funded residential schools,...
...most of them run by the Catholic Church.
They faced rampant neglect, physical, and sexual abuse,...
...while being forced to assimilate.